that moment it all sunken so um so my
last Court River of shitty soap so I
like talked to my lawyer
I was supposed to go get sense let's
stay so when you have a court date they
they get you up at like 3:00 in the
morning
yeah it's this big [ __ ] ordeal cuz
the jail you like go underground and
then you go into the courthouse kind of
deal
yeah so I'm like ready to go ready to
get sentenced and then like nothing oh
my god I'm like this is [ __ ] weird I
even woke up [ __ ] in like 3 o'clock
in the riot yeah cuz I was kind of
excited to get the [ __ ] out of county
jail
because that's all you're here in County
Jail prison is way [ __ ] better
totally as though yeah I mean if I had
to do the two if I had to do one of the
other I would definitely do prison but
but yeah so I'm sitting there and it's
like 11 o'clock I'm like what the [ __ ]
and you're in confinement so you can't
call anybody you can't you know can't
talk to anybody and finally they come
and might they put me in a room with my
lawyer he's like what the [ __ ] did you
do I go what I didn't do nothing I just
been [ __ ] sitting down in confinement
like rotting away yeah so uh he's like
yeah but some guard like I guess they
must have put me on some like weird like
like they have me like kind of red flag
to where I'm a threat to where they had
to like bring me out by myself kind of
like not like Hannibal Lecter like not
like that but like I had to be moved by
myself oh yeah no I know I look [ __ ]
insane when I cut [ __ ] I know I did I
was just like I haven't shaved like
hairs [ __ ] all crazy and then well it
was like well this is the best we can do
Rita they went down to seven years and I
was like let's [ __ ] do it because
it's like you just you've here 35 years
then 15 years for so long right yeah
you're like that's our whole [ __ ]
game they call it the boot like
everybody else in mates they call it the
boo game because that's what they 35
years 15 years 15 years and they're in
there for months like almost a whole
year of hearing you're getting 15 years
and then they finally like seven years
damn that sounds [ __ ] awesome yeah
and that's what they do take a [ __ ]
gift wrap because they get present on
Christmas morning yeah
it's I mean it's it's [ __ ] I mean
that's it's all a gaming this shit's all
the joke yeah system they beat you down
psychologically and they hit those
numbers and then is like you know 35 35
35 15 15 15 15 and then they hit you
with that which is still way too high
and they shouldn't even give you that in
the first place and they should like
actually address the problems that got
you in there in the first place yeah the
people rub and [ __ ] on the walls in
there they don't need to be in a prison
with all these people who are in there
for like drug abusers those people need
attention they need help to understand
why they're doing that
oh yeah but they they jail they jail
like people like that like that don't
need to be [ __ ] jail but a lot of
people I don't know it's [ __ ] you
should just kill child molesters and let
everything else is fine legalize
everything else yeah yeah I mean so
after you got the seven years what
happened next
um so you wait so I had to go back to
confinement and then I'm just I'm I'm
actually really [ __ ] excited now it
sucks I gots a new chapter it's a new
chapter I can get I finally know what I
got to do I can [ __ ] I can walk around
outside I can [ __ ] smoke cigarette I
mean that's all I'm worried about like I
can [ __ ] smoke cigarettes and walk
around outside yeah sign me up yeah
let's go because you're [ __ ] it
you're inside all the time
there's no windows or outside time and
County there's windows like this big but
it I didn't like looking outside because
it was so close to home that it kind of
like hurt looking outside yeah you know
what I mean you know that 49th Street
yeah yeah so that mean that kind of
sucks and then you can't you get a
little more freedom being up the road
like that then being in the county jail
so I remember so you go to these uh so
they it usually takes a few like a 3-4
days because they do a couple runs a
week to go to prisons yeah yeah I went
to Orlando and if you have like any self
conscious anything about you that [ __ ]
is gone dude do so you [ __ ] you're in
the you're in the vein you go to Orlando
you're they just pretty much beating you
down treating you like a piece of [ __ ]
taking away everything you are just you
[ __ ] your outside and with a
chain-link fence
and a horseshoe and there's probably
like I don't know I'd say 30 to 40 dudes
standing there but ass-naked
just like it's okay you know what I mean
really and like everybody's kind of been
up all night because you know the
Knights they do prison runs and you're
kind of like I hope this is it or I
don't rise there's gonna [ __ ] suck
because I had no idea I mean you [ __ ]
watch TV shows and [ __ ] like that you
don't know what to expect right kind of
deal and I didn't really know anybody my
uncle was the only one I went to prison
with but I don't really [ __ ] talk to
him about it cuz he found God and all
that good [ __ ] right so I think you know
about prison is don't drop the soap but
Oh beyond that yeah yeah so you getting
this thing and they they just they just
call you all kinds of names should you
like piece of [ __ ] you can't do not
really I mean you can't you could but
it's [ __ ] pointless to you because
they'll beat the [ __ ] out of you you
know what I mean like they'll handcuff
you and just beat the [ __ ] out of you so
you do that you get nakey to get
strip-searched and you guys you just
wait and you with your property you got
to get your [ __ ] everybody gets their
[ __ ] head and face shaved with like
the same [ __ ] nasty [ __ ] hose you
get your ID
just [ __ ] everybody's calling you an
idiot going through medical do all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then I remember finally
get to go to my [ __ ] dorm and I was
just like I remember laying on my bunk
on the top bunk and just looking at the
[ __ ] ceiling and be like oh alright
there we go yeah so it's like seven I
had eight months in so I figured what
the game time I kind of I was betting on
my game time I never went by the hole so
I was like ah we got lower five years
ago like okay so they call I remember I
just made it in time for like for Chow
and I'm like I don't want to go I'm like
I was just kind of like just lay down
and like this dude this dude I ended up
running into it a couple camps I was at
he's like come on [ __ ] they got
Yardbird tonight I'm like [ __ ] starboard
Yardbird it's a they had chicken like
couple of times yeah
yeah so my old ship wait what chicken so
when I first met they had actually like
they had real food like because you go
from County County is just like it's
like ALP oh man it's so bad yes that
food like dog food okay it's so [ __ ]
bad so by the time I get in it was like
six months of like real food like food
was actually it was decent you know what
I mean yeah
and then like every time a [ __ ] new
governor comes in I [ __ ] those boys
it's not a [ __ ] country club so we
got all swipe products all real so I
brought everything was [ __ ] soy wines
yeah cuz it was cheaper but dudes aren't
supposed to eat soy cuz it's a [ __ ]
it's an estrogen right right gives you
like tits oh yeah yeah I mean I got two
of those Thanks thanks for today do see
they they took one out they Tony our
neck so told me to go [ __ ] myself on the
second one but yeah wow yeah so uh yeah
I mean it's just it's just miserable
they just make it miserable
[Laughter]